Some of the best TV series of all time were
canceled too soon, but those overlooked classics
at least had enough episodes air to build
up a fanbase that was devastated when the
shows were pulled before their time.
Imagine how it must feel to be a creator,
producer, or star of a TV series that performed
so poorly that it was ripped off the air after
only a single episode.
Here are some shows that share that very unfortunate
distinction.
Co-Ed Fever
The biggest movie comedy of 1978 was National
Lampoon's Animal House, so naturally all three
broadcast TV networks at the time looked to
cash in on the craze.
CBS's attempt, Co-Ed Fever, was canceled before
it even debuted in its regular time slot,
thwarting countless wacky hijinks ...
"Why don't we all go over to Dean McPhee's
house and glue his wife to the ceiling?"
After the TV premiere of Rocky in 1979, CBS
had some time to fill, and aired a "special
preview" of the show, which was set on the
campus of a former women's college that had
just started admitting men.
While the show ranked a reasonable 19th in
the Nielsen ratings for the week, it lost
so much of the Rocky audience that CBS shut
it down completely.
Public Morals
In the '80s and '90s, producer Steven Bochco,
the creator of critically acclaimed hit shows
such as NYPD Blue, Hill Street Blues, and
L.A. Law, was just about the king of TV.
CBS jumped at the chance to get into the Bochco
business, and committed the laugh track-laden
Public Morals to its fall 1996 schedule.
Ratings and reviews for its October debut
were dismal, and the show about a vice squad
also suffered from bad timing: it premiered
in an election year that included a debate
over whether TV was growing too vulgar…because
of shows like Public Morals.
CBS canceled it after just one controversial
airing.
Emily's Reasons Why Not
ABC reportedly spent $5 million on an ad campaign
for the midseason launch of Emily's Reasons
Why Not, a 2006 sitcom about how dating is
hard and weird, starring the always likable
Heather Graham.
Graham starred as Emily, a woman unlucky in
love trying to figure out who not to date
and why.
Viewers must have decided there were plenty
of reasons why not to give the show a chance:
it lost more than a third of the audience
of its lead-in and lost a quarter of the audience
of The Bachelorette, the show that had occupied
its time slot a year earlier, which led to
ABC immediately pulling the plug.
Secret Talents of the Stars
One part Circus of the Stars, one part American
Idol, this reality competition show featured
celebrities known for one talent demonstrating
a different talent the general public didn't
know they had.
Just over 4-point-5 million people tuned in
to watch, to mention just one representative
example, country singer Clint Black try stand-up
comedy ...
"I am gonna use index cards tonight."
Viewers at home were supposed to vote for
their favorites each week—had CBS not canceled
the show after its first episode in April
2008.
Quarterlife
High-quality TV streaming on the internet?
It's common today, but in 2008 it was revolutionary.
Marshall Herskovitz and Edward Zwick, creators
of critically acclaimed dramas thirtysomething
and My So-Called Life, debuted Quarterlife
on MySpace, which was a hot social media platform
at the time.
The show was made to reflect its medium—episodes
were short and resembled YouTube clips, and
it looked like it was shot on webcams or hidden
cameras.
While there was no real precedent for what
constituted a hit streaming series in 2008,
enough people watched that NBC decided to
put it on terrestrial television.
After taking a few episodes and pasting them
together to fit an hour-long programming block,
its premiere brought in just 3.1 million viewers—the
worst mid-season ratings of an NBC show in
nearly two decades.
The network canceled the show and dumped the
five remaining prepared episodes onto its
cable counterpart, Bravo.
South of Sunset
Eagles singer and guitarist Glenn Frey didn't
fare nearly as well in his foray into dramatic
television as he'd done with smooth California
rock.
Very few viewers got a peaceful easy feeling
with South of Sunset, a lightly comic detective
show in which Frey starred as a former movie
studio security chief who opens his own private
investigations company in Beverly Hills.
Despite CBS frequently airing ads for the
show during its broadcast of the 1993 World
Series just before the premiere episode, only
nine percent of viewers tuned their dials
to South of Sunset.
The Los Angeles Times reported that the show
amassed "the lowest premiere ratings on record"
for a show on one of the Big Three networks
to date.
CBS put the show "on hiatus" almost immediately,
but South of Sunset never returned to the
schedule.
Osbournes: Reloaded
An attempted revival of MTV's The Osbournes,
Osbournes: Reloaded debuted in a plum post-American
Idol time slot in 2009.
It presented metal god Ozzy Osbourne and his
family at the center of a variety show featuring
pre-taped segments, sketches, audience participation
bits, and musical performances.
Following a high-profile preview episode,
nearly one in five Fox affiliates refused
to air further episodes of Osbournes: Reloaded
due to concerns over racy material and bad
language.
Critics were brutal: the Washington Post called
it "a revolting debacle" and "must-flee TV.",
Fox didn't even bother to air the rest of
the episodes already in the can.
Lawless
Fox apparently didn't learn much from CBS's
disastrous South of Sunset, and ordered up
another series about a private investigator
starring a famous non-actor.
Lawless starred standout University of Oklahoma
linebacker and Seattle Seahawks washout Brian
"The Boz" Bosworth as an ex-Special Forces
tough guy named John Lawless who unravels
mysteries in Miami.
Very few people wanted to see "The Boz" off
the gridiron, and Fox canceled the 1997 series
after its premiere episode.
"This just doesn't seem to be your lucky day."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!